hey everyone Spencer here and today
we're looking at more watchdogs 2 DLC
human conditions in this mission our job
is to hack a smart car and get it out of
a heavily guarded area if you had your
own multi-million dollar smart car where
would you drive it to leave your ideas
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video feel free to like share and
subscribe for more
yo wrench score jiggy zap I bet they use
these during their undercover sting
operations got any trouble with the band
no wkz hired you and I Suz extra
security after all these bomb threats
that they received may I tell me how
long have you been a kitty fun learn I
mean you know that ain't right when you
first saw the x-ray did you recognize
the action figure wedged inside your
rectum
yeah it was my wrench figure figure that
was the perfect hiding spot form wrench
did you give Marcus the USB yep where
you I was just telling him to jam that
puppy into one of those ek Z's computers
and I'll take it from there by the way
if they ever do make a retraction figure
they'd better glue the mask on so it
doesn't traumatize children you said it
like it's a bad thing
Oh
nine-one-one 11
Oh suspect is still in acidity let's
find him that'll do it
okay car
like magic could Ching
[ __ ] man the car isn't responding huh
now wrench hit in the game I'm trying to
turn the wheel and nothing is happening
how the hell am I supposed to drive the
damn car
oh yeah yeah hey mighty voice control
just talk to it talk to it you gotta be
joking no just talk to it a drive car
seriously exit the building closest exit
point driving tip not through the window
on a much better car voice you were
totally a fake car
get me the hell out of here alright
without killing me all appropriate
safety protocols will beep oh yeah
that's what I'm afraid of how do I
revert you to menu
that's what I'm afraid of
how do I revert you to manual control I
don't understand the question suspects
location the cops are on your s I know I
can't get control of the [ __ ] wheel
you try asking the car to give you
control
yes it didn't understand the question
well bypass the self-driving system are
you a hacker are you yeah yeah all right
I can do this before I get shot getting
shot and if I arrange your insurance I
nobody asked you
and what they found in their police
robots designed to fight protesters
location and searching for the suspect
now
yeah I just saw it that's why I called
your account is no longer suspended and
all those posts are gone
[ __ ] yeah I got manual control of the
car
I don't even ask what I had to do to get
it
you